hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter 6 of
book 4 Epictetus talks through a
reasoning process with the person who is
upset and being pitied and had other
people having compassion for what they
take to be that person's bad state or
unfortunate condition he has a lot of
really interesting things to say here
about
pity itself or compassion the record
that he's using here the verb is Olay
Elena Stein
that is the Greek down and it can mean
either pity or compassion it's it's some
sort of effective reaction towards the
other who is perceived as suffering or
in a bad state or in pain any of these
sorts of things right and this is
something that epictetus in fact says
that we want to feel towards those who
are doing poorly for example instead of
becoming angry at people who do stew
things or who misbehave we ought to
really feel pity why because the reason
why they're behaving in the way that
they do is because they're so
fundamentally screwed up in their views
on what is good for them and what is bad
for them what is right and wrong how
they should be behaving that they do the
things that they do so instead of
getting angry and and I wanted to you
know revenge ourselves upon them he says
we should feel pity and this is looked
at by by many people as a sign of some
sort of good character now a lot depends
what it is that we are pitying people
for or what it is that we are regarding
as some sort of evil which is the fall
on them which they have to endure which
they are living through it which we
might want to if not just sympathize
with them even to alleviate in some way
or to to the wail along with them so
here's the key question should we allow
being pitied by others to upset us
Epictetus
is dealing with a person who says I am
annoyed at being pitied and the first
things that Epictetus asks him is well
whose action is is it your action that's
that's the pitying or is it third action
and you know he says again let's think
about it another way is it in your power
to stop it
it's not in our power how other people
feel towards us whether they get angry
whether they are sad at our condition
whether they're happy whether they're
envious all of that is not in our
control that is their business not only
our business it's not within our power
Epictetus would say so already from a
story perspective you know the guys
should be recognizing
this is somebody else's business it's
not something that he has to worry about
so much but then you know here's what
anybody says I can show them I do not
deserve their pity why is he so bothered
because he thinks that he doesn't
deserve their pity maybe in fact he
doesn't although we're going to see
there's a paradox involved a little bit
later and we can think of all sorts of
cases where people are being pitied and
there's there's kind of a looking down
on the other person involved in and
being compassionate or pitying them this
could take all sorts of different modes
you know think about well here's a great
example the student who is taking out
you know loans and going to school
studying something that's not
immediately profitable that their family
can't quite understand because they were
real genuine desire perhaps even a
talent for that sort of thing and their
family are like more than that poor fool
I don't know what's going to become of
them look at not like they're successful
brothers sister over here the one who
you know we can look at saying this guy
or this this girl's got to put together
here's the historian here is the
philosopher here's the English major
here you know even worse here's what's
going to be a starving artist right
people will have a sense of pity about
them or think about for example on
disability when somebody has a
disability of whatever sort whether it's
mental or physical other people look at
them
and you know if they're not making fun
of them which is not a nice thing to do
they're saying things like oh sorry that
that's befallen you and we go through
all sorts of examples like that when
somebody gives alms to another person
because they're poor they're doing so
because they see the poverty as a bad
thing maybe there are some in some cases
in which we actually should have the
response of pity towards another person
but this person really wants to assert I
don't deserve pity I'm okay I want them
to recognize that I'm okay I think this
is a thing that we can all relate to as
well this is a common human experience
so epic assassin is deserving or not
deserving pity in our control that is in
our control whether we genuinely deserve
to be pitied or don't deserve to be
pinyon that is up to us because we have
a control over the aspect of our life at
least if we're understanding in a stoic
way now here's the the follow up is
being considered to be deserving of pity
in our control or not no that is not in
our control because that is up to other
people if we think that poverty is not
in itself a bad thing but they think
that poverty is indeed a bad thing
mistakenly and we happen to be
impoverished they are going to feel pity
towards us because they believe that we
deserve pity if you know we get to be
old and and we think that old age is not
a particularly bad thing for lucky
enough to get old right and other people
look at all the age and they say oh man
I am that's a terrible thing and then
they treat us nice as a result because
they feel a sense of compassion towards
us we don't control that we don't
control what other people think of and
deserving pity so you know that is
for them as Epictetus as grandmas say so
what it comes from that he says these
people do not pity me for what would
deserve pity if anything does that is my
mistakes but for poverty and now holding
office and things like disease and death
and the like
now how could we remedy this if this
really is a problem Epictetus says there
is a solution to that let's look at what
the solution would be if one really
wants not to be pitied by other people
for what considers to be the wrong
things then you got a couple choices
what are the choices well convince them
that they are the things that they think
are bad aren't really bad convince them
that poverty convince them that disease
convince them that not holding office
not not getting promoted not you know
having a successful romance all these
sorts of things that we did talk about
not going on vacation twice a year that
these are not really bad things so go
ahead and convince people of that or
here's another possibility maybe you
know make sure that you keep up
appearances if they think that being
rich is a great thing get yourself rich
that they won't be pitying you if they
think that it's really important to have
an attractive spouse or boyfriend or
girlfriend go start dating find yourself
somebody like that you know we could go
on if they think that having a good
office and getting promoted every so
often and getting Christmas bonuses is
where it's at go do that if you don't
want them to pity you and that really
really matters to you then you have
those two choices now how is this going
to pan out Epictetus wants us to see
that these are not really answers the
first one convincing the multitude he
says you're trying to accomplish the
very thing which God himself has but
then I'm able to
accomplished to convince all people of
what things are good and what are evil
now has that been given to you
no only this has been given to you to
convince yourself and you're not even
done with that yet so don't even think
about trying to convince everybody else
about what's genuinely good and evil
when you yourself are a bit mixed up
about it so that option isn't going to
work what about the appear to them to
have all the goods that they think are
good to not have the bad things right
how's that going to work
he says no are you prepared to show
yourself off to them as a rich man and
an official those are you know just two
things he'd need to do he doesn't say
anything about getting yourself some eye
candy to drag a lot on with you or about
having lots and lots of friends or about
naming University buildings after
yourself or any of the other things that
people might throw in right he says all
these alternative the second is the part
of a braggart and a tasteless and a
worthless person besides observe the
means by which you must achieve your
pretense you're gonna have to borrow
some servants and possess a few pieces
of silver plate and exhibit these same
pieces conspicuously and frequently if
you can and try not to let people know
that they are the same and possess
contemptible bright clothes and all
other kinds of finery and show yourself
off as the one who is honored by the
most distinguished persons try to dine
with them or they make people think that
you dine with them and resort to base
arts in the treatment of your person so
as to appear more shapely and a gentler
birth than you actually are
all these contrivance is you must adopt
if you want to take this second
alternative to of white pity in our own
day we might say alright you don't want
to feel you want anyone to have pity
Freeman get some credit cards start you
know buying some stuff make sure
everybody you know thinks that you
really have
together hit the gym a lot if you can't
really take the weight off miss a
liposuction we'll take care of that do
whatever you need to do in order to
appear successful to appeal to appear as
if you really have all the goods that
comprise what the many think to be a
good life now Kim can the average person
do that probably not and there are great
stories told about people who crash and
burn trying to do precisely that
sometimes a person may be able to pull
it off but what are you sacrificing by
doing that you can't actually work on
yourself and we do find people who have
devoted themselves to that sort of
external success of the body of external
possessions of you know social
relationships prestige who are extremely
unhappy and don't really understand
themselves and then you know they go
into therapy or counseling or you know
one form of working upon themselves and
they discover that they made the wrong
choice neither of these are the right
choice so what is the possibility don't
get upset about people pitying you pity
isn't in itself a bad thing do you think
it's a good thing when you do it for
other people
sure otherwise you wouldn't do it so why
are you so upset when people do it with
you and there's a paradox of being upset
by pity that epictetus is going to call
our attention to so let me walk you
through this this interesting paradox he
says don't you see what you're saying
about yourself what sort of person are
you in your own eyes what sort of a
person in thinking desiring avoiding in
choice preparation design and all the
other activities of human beings you are
concerned whether the rest of human
beings pity you listen yeah I don't
deserve to be pitied and so what does
that mean you're
that'd be a pity right of being Pina
being viewed as worthy of pity now is
the guy who is suffering worthy of pity
you see where this is going don't you by
the very emotion he says by which you
that you feel concerning pity you make
yourself worthy of pity so there's a
paradox by allowing oneself to be upset
over being pitied because other people
think that you deserve to be pitied
even if you don't you now deserve to be
pitied so if that's going to upset you
you're definitely going to be upset how
should we approach this then again we
should look at pity as something which
we can feel towards other people and
other people can feel towards us and
it's not hurting us in any way if they
do if they're getting things wrong if
they think that we deserve pity because
we're not rich we're not famous our
business ventures are not taking off
like gangbusters our you know spouse is
not a supermodel or or you know super
successful whatever that doesn't matter
those people want a pity us for those
let them that's their affair not ours
not something that is worth allowing
ourselves to become upset over if we do
want to become upset over that that we
actually do deserve pity